[Applause]
[Music]
spain is one of the countries with the
most problems of demographic aging in
the world
to give you an idea with the exception
of the microstates spain is in the top
10 countries with the highest average
age 43.3 years
and at the same time one of the 10
countries with the lowest fertility rate
in the case of spain barely 1.3 children
are born for every woman in a fertile
state far below the generational
replacement rate
take a look at how the aging index in
spain has evolved for example
today there are already 125 people over
64 for every 100 children under
16. the population permit is
increasingly
inverted
[Music]
and take note because this process is
going to accelerate a lot
over the next two decades why well
because 1958 and 1977 there was a huge
explosion in the birth rate
between these two years coinciding with
the economic takeoff of the country
almost 14 million children were born 4.5
million more than in the years following
and 2.5 million more than in the
previous 20 years
is spain's equivalent to the baby boomer
generation a generation that today
is increasingly close to retirement age
because of this
it is expected that by mid-century by
2050 the percentage of the population
over 65 years of age will increase from
to 30 this means that in just three
decades the population over 65 will
increase by more than six
million people and that is as long as
the average life expectancy does not
improve faster than expected despite all
the medical and technological advances a
development that would obviously be
extraordinary news
the problem is that apart from being
good news this also means a lot of
challenges for countries with aging
populations
like spain especially if we are talking
about pensions and especially if we are
dealing with public systems
[Music]
because my friends the pension system in
spain is essentially a public
pay-as-you-go system
that is the workers of the present pay
the pensions of their current retirees
while waiting for the workers of the
future to do the same
for them but of course if there are more
and more retirees and fewer bodies in
the working aid population
houston we have a serious problem and
this is precisely what explains why more
and more voices are warning of a
possible collapse in the pension system
at least the system as we know it
over the next two or three decades
[Music]
now having said that the question is why
should i care
well because spain is an economy within
the eurozone and we're talking about a
country of almost 47 million inhabitants
with a gdp of approximately 1.4 trillion
dollars
more or less 11 of the entire euro zone
gdp
[Music]
[Applause]
you see my friends spain is a country
with many problems a chronic deficit in
the public accounts a huge debt and very
little job creation well if we add to
all this the demographic aging and the
possible collapse of pensions what we
find is nothing short of a ticking time
bomb if things don't change drastically
spain in the same way as italy did could
leave the crisis in greece looking like
a comedy routine
what we're saying is that a financial
collapse in spain could drag down the
entire eurozone with it
and in spain the data seems clear it is
urgent
necessary pressing the implementation of
deep reforms to make the system viable
simply cannot be postponed so where
exactly are we
what financial problems is spain facing
are the pension system and public
finances
really in danger of collapse these are
the questions we intend to answer in
this new collaborations with our friends
at value school check out a discouraging
picture you see my friends in spain
there are problems that are beginning to
be very disturbing for example
using data from social security and the
national statistics institute this third
quarter would give a good economic
approximation of the state of the
country
[Music]
at the end of the third quarter of 2020
some 19 million people were working in
spain of which approximately 3.3 million
were in the public sector on the other
hand the state has to handle the payment
of 9.7 million pensions and almost 3
million
benefits for the unemployment that is
while in the private sector there are
slightly less than 16 million people
with a job
including of course temporary or
part-time jobs the public administration
has a commitment of more than 15 million
payments between payrolls pensions
and unemployment benefits
[Music]
a ratio that as you can see is
dangerously close to one
on one one worker in the private sector
for every check promised by the public
sector a level that
what can i say doesn't exactly look very
encouraging well
pay attention because everything points
to the fact that things could get quite
a bit worse
over the next few years in this video we
are going to focus specifically on
everyone's main concern
pensions which are by far the largest
item of public expenditure in spain
their weight in the public budget is
constantly growing to the point that the
central state is increasingly a pair of
pensions
on the one hand an increasing number of
people are opting to retire from working
life as soon as they hit 60 and on the
other
hand new retirees are drawing higher
pensions than those of pensioners who
have recently passed away
this is why since the year 2000 total
spending on pensions has increased by
approximately 160 percent
today already one out of three euros of
all public spending goes to pay for
pensions
[Music]
but that is not all as if these problems
were not big enough the public pension
system in spain is among the most
generous in the entire oecd
to give you an idea in net terms the
public pension at the time of retirement
represents 83 percent of an individual's
last salary by comparison the oecd
average
is 58.6
in other words public pensions in spain
are more generous than those of
countries like germany
sweden norway or denmark
the fact is that as we mentioned before
in spain the pension system is
essentially a public pay-as-you-go
system people who are working pay the
pensions of those
who are already retired the big problem
with that is that as you have seen for
several years now the numbers haven't
balanced
neither above nor below neither on one
side
nor on the other
in 2019 the spanish pension system had a
deficit of about 17 billion euros by
2020 with the corona virus to deal with
this shortfall will increase to about 45
billion euros
that is despite making some of the
highest social contributions in the
world
spanish workers today are no longer able
to finance all the pensions being paid
and this situation
only promises to get much worse listen
up because this real horror story could
turn into a total nightmare for the euro
a future tinged with doubt
[Music]
okay so things are already looking bad
but it looks like they're about to get
a lot worse as we've already said spain
is one of the countries most affected by
demographic aging
in the world and that is something that
will have consequences
by the middle of the century is expected
and this is important for the dependency
rate that is to say the percentage of
people over 66 years of age in relation
to those of working age will be around
60 in other words if today there are 3.3
people of working age for every person
over 65
in 2050 this figure will be less than
1.8
[Music]
but of course not everyone who is of
working age will have a job there will
be students the unemployed the disabled
and people who simply choose
not to work for example according to
eurostat data the employment rate
amongst people aged 20 to 65
i.e the percentage of people in that age
range who were working for the year 2019
was above 80 in countries such as
germany the netherlands and sweden but
only 68
in spain
and take note because this is not
something temporary in the last century
this rate has never been higher than 70
percent so if we take this into account
even if things were improved we could
find ourselves in 2050 with a ratio of 1
to 1.2 workers
to every pensioner and to top it off
productivity levels in spain are not
exactly nasa grade either
[Applause]
you see as we approach the year 2050 the
burden of pensions on each worker is
going to be even greater and remember
that the system
is already in the red and then of course
to all this spending we also have to add
the payroll of public employees
unemployment benefits subsidies of all
kinds and potentially
much higher healthcare spending
[Music]
because demographic aging does not only
translate into more pensions but also
into higher
health and dependency costs and the
question we need to ask is
where will all the money necessary to
make those commitments come from will
spain really be able to pay
15 million pensions
please note that these are not minor
questions international bodies such as
the oecd
the international monetary fund and the
european commission have been warning
about the threat of spain's public
accounts
for years for example in order for the
pension system to remain unchanged
that is assuming the current deficit and
the current average pension spain would
need the number of social security
members
that is workers paying into the system
to exceed 29 million
to give you an idea that would mean
increasing the workforce by more than 50
percent
and if we are talking exclusively about
the private sector then we are talking
about an increase of more than 80
percent
all this in a context of demographic
aging it just seems
like an impossible mission
[Music]
and as we have already said it's not
only about the social security system
in the end it is the state that pays and
in that respect
things are no better either spain will
emerge from the stars coronavirus 2
pandemic with a record level public debt
around 120
of gdp a chronic public deficit high
unemployment and a very weak business
environment
whichever way you look at it the
scenario doesn't look good
spain needs urgent reforms but its
political class is not in favor of the
task
on the contrary there is not even an
open debate on the pension system
even though it is clearly heading
towards the abyss
for example the strongest pension
systems in the world have one common
feature they all have strong savings and
capitalization components
that is they are not essentially based
on the pay-as-you-go formula however
in spain this is a kind of no-go zone
for the political class
in fact the system is not only
essentially public and pay-as-you-go but
in recent years some benefits that
previously existed to encourage
spaniards to save for their future
have now been eliminated
but of course as we mentioned before it
is not only about spain a crisis as big
as the collapse of the spanish pension
system could drag down the entire
eurozone
and then what a new bailout
so now it's over to you how do you see
the future of pensions
what reforms do you think should be
carried out leave your answer in the
comments below as always we really hope
you enjoyed this video please hit like
if you did and don't forget to subscribe
for brand new videos don't forget to
check out our friends too
at the reconsider media podcast they
provided the vocals in this episode that
were not my dulcet tones also
this channel is possible because of
patreon and our patrons on that platform
please consider joining them and
supporting our mission of providing
independent political coverage and
as always i'll see you next time and if
you want to learn more about politics
and hear even more of my lovely voice
you can join us at reconsider media we
have a podcast at reconsider media.com
podcast see you there